right now Ted Cruz in his Senate race
down there in the state of Texas is
fighting for his life okay the latest
rounds of polling that come out this
week show Democratic challenger Beto
O'Rourke within one point of Ted Cruz
which means given the margin of error
this is a statistical tie between Ted
Cruz who was once considered one of the
safest Republicans in the country and
Beto O'Rourke so Ted Cruz called in his
billionaire donors and they're a little
reluctant I got to be honest they don't
know if they want to go down there and
spend a ton of money but he finally
found one that's willing to Club for
Growth they have announced that they're
gonna come in with a seven-figure ad buy
to make sure that they can attack Beto
O'Rourke and ensure a Ted Cruz victory
they're iffy they're not certain it's
gonna work but they're gonna do their
best but what's happening right now with
Ted Cruz and we've seen this happening
with Republicans all over the country is
that their billionaire and millionaire
donors are starting to realize that some
of these Republicans and Ted Cruz is one
of them might be a bad investment
because after all when you're a
multinational corporation when you're in
the top 1% you want to spend your money
in a way that's going to give you some
kind of return that's why corporations
and wealthy people buy politicians they
get something out of it but sometimes
you have a politician who basically ends
up being the equivalent of Enron stock
you think it's going well you think
things are great only to find out uh-oh
you just lost everything and that's what
happens when these millionaires and
billionaires put money into a candidate
who loses so they're reluctant at this
point to give Ted Cruz more money but
the Club for Growth whose biggest thing
is cutting taxes for the wealthy elite
they have faith in Ted Cruz at least
enough faith to come down to Texas and
spend you know ten million dollars or
more on these major ad buys but what's
going to happen down here in the state
of Texas is going to be fun to watch
play out because you have Democrat
challenger Beto will work he's
challenged use me the state County to
County walking around talking to people
okay finding out what they want you know
finding out what they want their
representatives to do in Washington DC
listening to the people again something
we don't see happening enough in this
country with politicians and his video
is viral video that he had talking about
the NFL players protesting you know Ted
Cruz has kind of jumped on that he's
trying to make that the campaign issue
saying Beto O'Rourke's supports
protesting the national anthem but if
you follow Ted Cruz's Twitter feed and
you see when he posts this stuff read
through the comments people aren't
buying it at least not the people online
they understand that better or work did
not say that people should protest the
national anthem they have a right to
protest the police brutality that's
happening in this country during the
national anthem which is what these
protests are all about Ted Cruz is
trying to spin it and he's losing that
battle but there is another side of the
coin here for Ted Cruz that is leaving a
bad taste in voters mouths in Texas and
that is the fact that this man got so
bullied and badly beaten during the 2016
Republican primaries by Donald Trump
that they don't know if they think he's
a stand-up fighter kind of guy hey let's
go back through Donald Trump mocked Cruz
relentlessly he insulted his wife's
appearance he also helped to spread the
conspiracy theory that Ted Cruz's father
was somehow involved in the JFK
assassination and in spite of all of
that Ted Cruz has been a Donald Trump
suck-up since the day that man was sworn
into office and now sensing that he is
in deep trouble down there in the state
of Texas he is actually asking the White
House to send Donald Trump down to Texas
to do a rally for him to kind of drum up
some more support you know things are a
little slow for him so he is reaching
out to this man who in
salted you know half of the guy's family
tree and voters in Texas are looking at
him say wait a minute really you're
gonna you're gonna do that to yourself
you're gonna subjugate yourself in that
kind of manner to a man who absolutely
berated you your wife your father
everyone you've cared about but you want
to win so much that you're willing to
put do your honor for your family aside
yeah not exactly the kind of person we
want representing this state in the US
Senate and that's what cruises up
against right now I am fairing cousins
if you want more from me you can find me
on youtube at youtube.com slash the Ring
of Fire follow me on Twitter at fair and
balanced we'll be right back with more
the David Pakman show today's program is
sponsored in part by
blinkin we all lead busy lives sometimes
it can sort of become a struggle to do
all the reading that we want to do I
know this is certainly true for me there
are probably a bunch of books that
you've been hoping to sit down with and
read but you've not yet been able to
find the time what if I told you that
you could read a full-size book in 15
minutes or even more quickly
that's basically what blink as'll aoz
you to do blankest is a mobile app that
takes thousands of the most popular and
critically acclaimed non-fiction books
and summarizes them into their most
important points and they present it to
you in the form of text or audio so that
you can either read it or listen to it
in 15 minutes you get all the same
information and insight from the book in
a fraction of the time you can search by
author or topic new books are being
added all the time it's an almost
endless diverse collection to choose
from politics science health and fitness
psychology parenting business you're not
going to run out I think is the point
I'm trying to make of fascinating
informative nonfiction reading and
listening material and blink astiz free
to try and membership after that is only
a few bucks a month and you can get a
20% discount off of that if
you go to blink is comm slash Pakman if
you're watching on YouTube we've put a
link in the description underneath the
video that is blink accom /p a que ma n